this idea of keeping up with the joneses
you know the joneses are broke they they
are living paycheck to paycheck what you
see
a lot of the time not all the time but a
lot of the time it's leveraged it's not
even their money they don't even have
the money to pay for these things and so
when you're comparing yourself against
people like that you're gonna end up in
the same position it's a time of
sacrifice like you said i love what you
said about it because it's so true it's
gonna be hard you're gonna be saying no
when you wanna say yes all of it but
it's for a short period of time we we
stay at ramsey solutions to live like no
one else because no one's doing that no
one is living at that sacrificial level
much anymore you live like no one else
so later you can live and give like no
one else there's something about when
you give and you live life with an open
hand there is a
there's a joy i think there's a peace
there's something that comes with
the idea that you're doing this not just
for you
that was rachel cruz a two-time number
one national best-selling author
financial expert and host of the rachel
cruz show rachel empowers people to turn
around their finances win with money and
build a life they love she's an
energetic and thought-provoking speaker
and has been speaking to audiences as
large as 10 000 since the age of 15 when
she began making appearances with her
father dave ramsey this is an important
conversation for all people at all
levels of income rachel's message is
that at any point in life you can start
making shifts in your spending to get
out of debt build savings and create
long-term wealth i personally have
learned so much from her father dave
ramsey and have seen drastic shifts in
not only my own life but also my
friend's life by following the
principles both rachel and dave teach
i'm so excited to read rachel's book
know yourself know your money which is
out now and available to read sometimes
it can be uncomfortable to even tackle
the topic of finances or wanting to
build your own wealth can seem selfish
but this conversation really sets the
table for not only growing in your own
mindset and ease of stress in life when
it comes to money but also to give
generously which is one of the biggest
aspects of this conversation in my
opinion
in this episode we cover building a
wealth mindset the common
characteristics that wealthy people live
by
myths that people believe about
millionaires the biggest mistakes people
make when managing their own money how
to make budgeting rewarding and exciting
the importance of short-term sacrifice
for long-term goals taking life and your
money into your own hands and why giving
generously is such an integral part of
the goal and conversation we even get
into teaching your kids about having
healthy finances i enjoyed this
conversation so much and found it very
inspiring i hope by the end of this you
feel empowered hopeful and ready to take
action in your own life let's get
started all right welcome to the podcast
rachel i am so happy to have you as a
guest thank you for being here oh thanks
ellen thanks for having me this is so
fun of course so i want to jump right in
because it's such an exciting and
empowering topic but before i do i would
love to just know
like what makes you so passionate about
this topic of taking charge of your
personal finances and what changes have
you seen from this message
yeah well it kind of i think my passion
came out of my own story
i grew up
in a family that actually declared
bankruptcy the year i was born
and so out of that my parents really
tried to figure out okay how does money
really work because obviously we tried
doing it our way and it didn't work and
now we want to figure out the truth so
out of that came um really this message
of financial freedom what does it look
like to live intentionally what does it
look like to be on a budget what does it
look like to be debt free um all of that
and so my dad really for my whole
childhood that was his job and so
um his career kind of grew from the
bottom up through my high school days
like from elementary school to high
school and
in high school i started traveling and
speaking with him and it would be in
these arena type events when i was in
high school and i loved it so i knew
early on that i enjoyed
that i enjoyed you know speaking in
front of people which is very rare
so
i kind of tucked that away and then when
i went to college
i realized the need for this message you
know i was talking to these 18 year olds
and they were already signing up for
credit cards i had student loan debt and
all of this and i thought you know i
don't know a lot at 18 but i know enough
that i feel like if they made different
decisions today they could avoid
so much financial pain in the future
that they're literally causing
themselves now that they don't realize
and so when i graduated from college is
when i said okay this is what i want to
do i want to really kind of you know
dedicate my life in a sense in my job
and my career to helping people
get in control of their money because
money is such a
it can be a really shameful uh topic for
a lot of people it's embarrassing uh
because money fault your your money
mistakes follow you there's a number
attached to those mistakes and so
there's a lot of that feeling around
finances and so to kind of peel that off
of people and give them a lot of hope
and a lot of grace to say hey you may
have made some mistakes in the past but
you have the opportunity to wake up
today and make decisions with your money
where actually money doesn't have to be
this stressful
uh burdensome topic in your life it
actually can be very freeing very
hopeful and stress-free
yeah that's such powerful information
and for anybody who doesn't know
her dad is dave ramsey and maybe you
could talk a little bit about that like
what it was like growing up as his
daughter if you don't know his book the
total money makeover is just has changed
so many people's lives even in my own
personal life i know so many people
whose lives it has completely changed
the trajectory of the life that that
they were headed towards and brought
them to like a totally different path um
so it's yeah it's really impactful and
even my husband and i we read that book
years ago and
we listened to his show where he's like
talking to people who call in when we're
on our way to like sports events for the
kids and the kids are in the back
and my eldest is really into it too so
he knows who dave ramsey is so yeah
i love it i love it so good yeah you
know i think people kind of assume when
they hear oh dave ramsey's your dad
that we had like mutual funds birthday
parties and like
budget camps in the summer and all this
like crazy
money-centric household and that really
was not the case i mean mom and dad they
did a really great job teaching us how
money works but it was very casual
really in the ebb and flow of life it
wasn't this
unorganic sit down
we're gonna have meetings about this and
all you know it was not legalistic at
all it was actually a very freeing
topic in our household but they were
intentional about it because just like
you are
teaching your kids you know to brush
their teeth or how to study for school
you know you teach them these lessons
these things that they take with them
into adulthood
to be great adults and so money is just
one of those things so yeah mom and dad
were much more i think chill
uh than people probably think they were
yeah than you expect
yes
that's awesome so for people who are
listening i think a lot of people
struggle and they fee they feel like
they're struggling with their finances
they want they want to become more
financially independent and or just
financially stable but they don't really
know how to shift their circumstances or
feel a little bit lost and feel like
they won't be able to change their
circumstances so what do you think is
the best advice for people on how to
build like a a wealth mindset
yes well you have to realize that
personal finance it's 80 behavior
it's really only 20 head knowledge so
understanding what to do is not the
problem it's actually doing it
and the issue is that we live in a
culture that honestly a lot of the
messages and a lot of the normal things
in our culture when it comes to money
are keeping people broke i mean
everything from
you know living in debt uh enjoying
whatever you want when you want it kind
of that yolo mentality um you know
there's there's these compounding ideas
and principles that
now have caused 78 of americans to live
paycheck to paycheck it's caused the
average household to have 16 000 in
credit card debt it's caused people to
think that you just can't go to school
without a student loan um that you have
to have a credit card to survive in life
today and you know all of this stuff
these this mindset and what it's caused
again is
is a lot of stress for people and this
idea that they're completely out of
control so my my um advice or my
encouragement would be that if you feel
like you're stuck and you feel like oh
what i'm doing is not working
that you actually can change you
actually can say hey i can learn some
new things that i thought i thought went
away but maybe i'm going to think a
different way
but doing it is what's hard and nobody
likes change
and so we we don't take into account i
think a lot of our human spirit when it
comes to money we kind of just think of
money as numbers and you add subtract
divide multiply like that's money
but really there's so much emotion
behind money because it's you a person
that's dealing with it you know the
money is not the issue with those dollar
bills sitting in front of you it's you
who's handling it that has the issues
right we all do and so learning to deal
with yourself in the process is really
big and and again a part of that is
going to be changing your mindset it's
going to be changing your habits and
there's going to be friction
i have three kids uh they're seven
four and two and when our two-year-old
was born we uh we got a minivan ellen we
uh we we
you know we did it we we took one for
the team and we got a minivan and i was
cleaning it out one of the first times
and and i switched the car seats of my
infants and my two-year-old at the time
because i just took them out i was
cleaning everything i switched them and
my two-year-old got in the car and it
was not the right side of the van that
she was supposed to sit in you know and
you know with kids you just know it's
just drama and they're just freaking out
she's throwing a fish like i'm this is
not my side of the van no no no no
and i just thought man even at two years
old she doesn't like change right she is
used to one thing
and the moment you change it it's
uncomfortable so my encouragement to be
able to hey the change that you're gonna
make uh is so possible you can learn
this stuff you don't have to have a
master's degree in finance to win with
money
but you're gonna have to change behavior
and that's going to be the uncomfortable
part
oh i'm so glad you brought up that
example with the two-year-old it's a
great example and a good reminder to be
like look like we all struggle or a lot
of people struggle with change
um and i have not caved and got a
minivan yet
my husband we have four kids actually
very similar age to yours i have a
ten-year-old
almost seven uh four-year-old and almost
two-year-old oh my gosh yeah and then
another one on the way so yeah my
husband's like i think it's time oh
thank you he's like i think it's time
i'm like no i don't want him
my husband wanted one and i was like no
i'm an suv kind of girl but i'm telling
you ellen i i bit the bullet and it's
and it's amazing everyone says that
everybody has more cup holders than you
can imagine you just when you get in it
you just can't
you just can't tell yourself you're in a
minivan you know you gotta really you
gotta get over the hump
it's so worth it and it's my i told him
when we bought it i was like it's my
five-year car like when our youngest
goes to kindergarten
i'm gonna get the cool mom suv i'm gonna
do it
so if i have if i have an end date it
helps yeah yeah that's such a good idea
it's so true once they're out of car
seats you can get any car any car it
doesn't have to be a minivan it's so
true i know they have to be older than
kindergarten though i think like just
with all the car seats it's like it
really is hard to stuff it in the car
um but i love just the way that you're
talking about money mindset because a
lot of times money can be such a dirty
word like even just talking about like
building wealth it can sometimes be
associated with
selfishness or just a negative thing
right as if it's a bad thing to
grow your wealth and to i don't know
just to have a savings account and to
not be in debt right even just talking
about it is kind of has these negative
connotations but you're so right that
it's so emotionally driven and
this like issue with money we can't just
look at it as dollar signs like it
really affects our well-being um
throughout everything in our life if
we're
not um struggling so much it makes it
does help help life to not feel as
stressful
and that's not to say that like oh money
solves all your problems but it can
definitely help when you're not in a
place of owing money to
other people and kind of being like the
the person that's just tied to all these
different things
you're exactly right it's unbelievable
you know i um i heard this once that i
loved it's that money is amoral right
it's not good it's not bad it literally
is just money but when you put it in the
hands of a person
we decide whether we use it for good or
we use it for bad and the hard thing is
like yeah the idea of oh rich people are
wealthy people there's this stereotype
with it but what's fascinating and i'm
sure everyone can relate i'm like i have
met wealthy people that are some of the
most generous kind
easy going
look under the radar you would never
know
but are extremely wealthy and then you
meet wealthy people that are gross and
you're like i'm taking a shower after
hanging out with you because you're just
kind of slimy and i don't i don't like
you
but i've met people that don't have a
lot of money and they're broke living
paycheck to paycheck who are some of the
most stingy
selfish they they're watching their back
all the time they're they're you know i
mean they're just not always kind people
and then you meet people that don't have
a lot of money and they're some of the
most generous
kind peaceful people you know what i'm
saying like yes it doesn't matter the
amount of money what happens is what who
you are and so money's a magnifying
glass it makes you more of what you
already are so if you are kind of a more
selfish
jerky person and you get a lot of money
that's what's magnified right but if
you're someone who's like hey i want to
take care of my family i want to be
generous to other people i see money as
a tool to help me in my life it's not my
identity my net worth is not my
self-worth this is a literal tool in
life to use to help my family help my
kids
um you know maybe help pay for college
would it take him on a great experience
and um yeah not have the stress actually
have a
have a safety net of a savings account
an emergency fund uh and we get to we
get to we have overflow so we get to
help people like you get to give to
organizations or people who need it and
it's the most joyous thing you can do
with money like you you get to do that
when you have money um so there's
something about that that is magnified
in you so your character in the midst of
this whole journey is really important
yes so important to explain that i think
that's super super helpful and through
this whole topic of people feeling stuck
and you're talking about
the you said 78 of people living
paycheck to paycheck like that's
astounding and yet a lot of people
there's a huge portion of people who
really believe that they are
a victim to their circumstances and they
are stuck to where they are and they
cannot change their circumstances at all
when the message that you share is so
empowering and it really gives people
the tools and step-by-step process to
help them get out of debt to help people
to start building a savings and to have
that opportunity like to do all these
things that you're talking about to be
generous with your money and to also
have the ability to take care of your
family and have a little bit left over
and stuff like that so yeah so i i
definitely want to get into a little bit
about millionaires like the myths of
millionaires because
like what we were just saying it's easy
to think oh look all these people over
here there's nothing we can do about it
this is this is just the place that
we're in and it has nothing to do with
your choices right and then all these
people over here who are millionaires or
billionaires or whatever it inherited
their money and they're just living the
good life going to golf courses on their
ferrari and everything like that but
like let's just break this down can you
please explain to people like the most
common
myths of
that people believe about millionaires
yes so a few years ago we did the
largest study of millionaires that's
ever been done
and so we studied the and we call them
we you know we call them these baby
steps millionaires it's a lot of people
that have done our plan that have become
wealthy um and really it's these
everyday people it's these people that
really flander like you said you think
you know you have the stereotype in your
head of what they're driving what
they're wearing and some people do that
and it's not and i wouldn't even say
that's right or wrong you know but
totally that's not that's not always
that's not the reality so one of the
biggest myths is that yeah that that
they inherit their money that you know
if you're a millionaire or you become
wealthy it's because your family has
when in fact 79 of millionaires today
have never received an inheritance
79 so that's 8 out of 10 millionaires
have never received a dime
and then another myth is that
they went to like prestigious schools
right and that they're part of this
elite that is untouchable and they get
this education they kind of get the
secret
of the rich and and they know this stuff
that i don't when the truth is that 62
percent went to public universities wow
and so you know you look and say okay
well majority of millionaires literally
went to public universities and then
another myth is that yeah they live this
lavish lifestyle
um when in fact we we
found in the research the top three
uh careers of millionaires is an
engineer an accountant and a teacher
number three that that's a shocking one
that's surprising the teacher one
especially oh for sure so it's not you
know no an engineer makes you know a
great living and you know i count all of
that but it's not always the doctors and
the lawyers and you know what you think
out there so it really is these everyday
people
and to be able to say okay what do i do
with my money how do i
build wealth how do i how am i smart
with my money um and it is it's it's it
really kind of breaks down those
stereotypes
yeah because i think it's easy to even
just assume oh if you're an engineer
then they all have a lot of money but
you can be a totally broke engineer or
you can be a millionaire engineer and
have a very similar job yeah yeah and
because it really comes down to how you
spend your money and how you save your
money i think something within that
study that was really shocking to my
husband and i was
um something about the percent of people
that never made over a hundred grand
in a single year something about that
like that that's really surprising i
think because a lot of times you think
millionaire there just must be making
you know five hundred thousand a million
dollars every year um what what's the
deal with that yeah well because it just
proves that it's your attack it's your
habits
that cause you to become wealthy and win
with money over time it's not
necessarily that dollar that's coming in
now if you have a bigger shovel does it
help absolutely but you could be making
five hundred thousand dollars
and still be broke because totally
spending everything you make right yes
so your habits yeah it doesn't dictate
and that's the problem even when people
get raises or they you know get a higher
income i call it lifestyle creep because
they keep the same habits they just get
more money to add to the habits so if
you have good habits it doesn't matter
really with that income coming in when
you're smart with it and you know what
you're doing
um you're being intentional with it that
you can build wealth over time and and
these millionaires in this study
majority of them the the million dollar
net worth came from a paid off home
so their mortgage was paid off and money
in their 401k that they're investing so
again it's not this sneak behind the
door
hedge fund strategy thing that no one
knows about you know it's not like this
this idea of oh i can't i can't do that
it's very attainable it's very
obtainable right and that's not to say
that like everyone's gonna be making the
same amount the whole point of this
specific study talking about this is to
show it's how you handle your money and
a lot of times what you're saying people
start making more and then they're like
oh now i gotta spend more and then you
just end up spending
more and more and more before you know
it you're just as broke as you were 10
years ago when you're making a hundred
thousand less
and that is so fascinating yeah and that
that's all that's the money's not a
band-aid it's not gonna it's not gonna
solve your issues right it's you right
and what you do with it that really
changes it yeah and there's like people
in my life growing up that you on the
surface would think oh they must have a
lot of money the way that they live
their life right maybe the cars they
drive or the restaurants they go to the
amount of money they spend on a bottle
of wine even just take something like
that for example versus maybe another
family who you see them driving maybe a
quite cheap car
and not living extravagantly maybe going
to cheaper restaurants or not even going
to restaurants at all or hardly at all
and you find out oh this person this
family actually has like four times the
amount of money as maybe this other
family because of how they chose to
spend it i think that's really
encouraging for people who are in a
place who like okay i only make you know
this amount of money per year i'm not
going to even make close to 100 000 a
year but you have the power and the
control to decide how you spend the
money that you do make and that's really
really helpful i think
absolutely and you made a good point too
that stop looking at everyone around you
like put the blinders on yes because
this idea of keeping up with the joneses
you know the joneses are broke they they
are living paycheck to paycheck what you
see
a lot of the time not all the time but a
lot of the time it's leveraged it's not
even their money they don't even have
the money to pay for these things and so
when you're comparing yourself against
people like that you're going to end up
in the same position so again it's not
to judge someone that you know drives a
nice car i kind of got i'm a little
guilty of it ellen like i kind of went
through a season of my life someone that
like was on had a nice vacation it was
on instagram i was like i bet they just
charged everything on a credit card like
i would like get like frustrated and i'm
like no rachel like stop it it doesn't
matter what they did be happy for them
be excited for them but to really put
those blinders on though and what other
people choose to do with their life that
is there that's you know they can do it
but for you and your family or for you
man
focus on what what is best for you guys
because that's what's most important
yeah and i think when you bring up the
keeping up with the joneses part i think
that's really helpful
to realize a lot of people maybe you're
in the beginning of your maybe growth of
your income and you think i got to live
like this person because you're just
constantly comparing yourself when
you're not making that kind of money to
be able to live like that person at
least yet right that's not to say that
you're never going to maybe you never
will
but i think what's so helpful at least
what my husband and i have found over
our years is to
focus on the long-term goals like for us
we're like short-term hard
work and for the long-term goals so we
would like from the very beginning
you know the way that we lived living in
like the cheapest rent we could find and
saving every dollar we could get my
husband was working like 60 hours a week
when we first moved to hawaii because we
like just didn't want to dip into our
savings we had a savings but we're like
we have the goal to buy a house one day
so we're not gonna live like we have
that money we're gonna just keep working
really hard and saving as much as we can
buying the cheapest car we could that
was functioning
like a 4 000 car i think is what we did
in the beginning and just little steps
like that that a lot of times if you're
living in a different way it makes it a
lot harder for you to save to eventually
be able to buy a house so i'm sure we'll
get into all these steps but i just
thought it would be interesting to kind
of share a little bit about our personal
personal growth
in that aspect
so what are some like common
characteristics that um people live by
who are wealthy or are good with their
money aside from these things you just
talked about
yeah i mean i think one thing is that
they don't give in to instant
gratification so there's something to be
said about every time you see something
you want and there's like this knee-jerk
reaction that you're like oh i can get
it i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get it and
through the avenue of debt you really
can you can get a lot of things that you
want even if you don't have the money
for it and so what i've learned people
over time that have built wealth
they have this level of delayed
gratification if they want something
they're like okay
i i can get that and i want that but i'm
gonna work for it like there's this idea
of paying a price to get it versus just
doing what feels good in the moment and
so there's this delaying pleasure
again and it's a character quality
you'll see it throughout their whole
life that you're like okay wow they do a
great job of kind of stepping back
assessing the situation figuring out how
to go about it in the wisest way versus
doing this you know knee-jerk reaction
i'd say that
um people that went with money long-term
they're very intentional with their
money nothing happens by accident you
know you think about
you know the olympics or the super bowl
you know these big athletic events and
it's not like people just
end up there and like oh hey i have some
skates and
i think i'm gonna skate today maybe i
will i don't know you know no there was
a plan they knew exactly what they did
they the sacrifice required to win at
that level you know you look at that
none of that's by accident and so the
same with money is that this doesn't
just happen they have a plan they know
what's going on they're intentional with
their income
that's a big one and then one that we
found in our millionaire study is you
know the idea that your your income is
your largest wealth building tool so in
order to build wealth to buy a house
like you were talking about to save up
to invest all of it you need money and
you need your income but when your
income
is going out eight different directions
to payments
then you don't have a lot of income left
to go and build wealth with so
getting out of debt and being debt free
was a huge part of freeing up that
income to say oh wow we actually have
money
sitting in our account that we get to
decide what to do with
perfect
yeah i think a lot of people feel like
they're struggling because they have all
these payments and you don't really know
where to go from there so
i guess
i guess the word is like budgeting that
you're really kind of well known for is
is your budget it's not a sexy word it's
kind of a boring word it sounds like a
little bit lame even like oh i don't
wanna budget right but what are the
powers of budgeting and what what growth
will you see from that
it's so huge and i
personally i'm a natural spender so
you're kind of either naturally a saver
spinner i'm a spender and i'm more of
kind of a free spirit i'm not great at
details like i'm the personality that
should not be loving i should not love a
budget right and so for so long i didn't
i mean i was i always thought a budget
you know
it felt cheap it felt constricting
it felt like oh i have to say no you
know every time i heard the word budget
it was like well we can't go out to eat
we're on a budget or we're not going on
vacation this year we're on a budget i'm
not going shopping i'm on a budget and
i'm like people on budgets are not fun
people
like if that is what living life is on a
budget i'm like no thank you can i just
enjoy my life yeah and so i had this
negative connotation with a budget for a
really long time and then after my
husband and i we got married and he's
actually the one that was like hey we
need to do a budget and i was like oh
i know i need to you know i grew up as
dave ramsey's kid so i'm like in my head
i know i need to but doing it it just
wasn't i was like i don't know we will
i'm telling you ellen after living with
one for
you know even five six months at that
point we made a budget every month there
was this level of freedom that i got
from the budget that i never expected
that i'm like i can still
go shopping like we can still go on
vacation we can still do these things
but we're doing it with a limit and a
boundary for sure but i actually have
permission to spend like when i'm
spending money and i'm buying something
i'm not second-guessing and thinking oh
is this too much should this be
you know money going to groceries this
week is this
do i am i going to have enough here like
all of the answers all of the questions
are answered because you have a plan and
you know exactly where your money's
going and there's something powerful
about that so i really do look at a
budget as permission to spend it allows
you to still live your life
you will have boundaries and limits for
sure because i want you to budget with
just your income i don't want you to go
over your income and go into debt
but but there's this level of okay we
can do things and have peace about it
versus questions and stress
right so then what are some tips and
resources for people who are like maybe
they're in debt and they have
college loans or they have car payment
and they want they love what you're
saying they're like yes okay i'm down i
would love to start building my wealth
and not living in debt but how do i get
there what how do you start a budget and
get out of debt yes great question okay
so the budget we'll we'll tackle that
first so i always recommend doing a
monthly budget and doing it before the
month begins so you're going to take
your income and you can do this on excel
you can do this on a sheet of paper we
have a budgeting app called every dollar
it doesn't matter you just do it
somewhere because i want it visual some
people will say oh well my budget it's
in my head and i'm like no it doesn't
work you got to have you got to see the
numbers it needs to be visual so write
your income at the top and if you
are freelance or you work on commission
you know you may not know the exact
number so i always say just kind of
guesstimate just kind of figure out okay
here's like at least the lowest amount i
know for sure i'm going to make and then
you're going to list out all of your
categories so you're going to do this in
different sections so the first category
i always recommend is giving
you want to be giving no matter where
you are financially even if it's a
little bit
i really really would encourage you just
give something start that habit now
because people think well once i
actually get money
it'll come easier and actually it
doesn't it doesn't because again the
magnifying glass remember that it makes
you more of what you are so start being
a giver now so give something
and then look at your four walls so
that's your food
shelter utilities and transportation
these are your needs so making sure
those are covered and then everything
else underneath and this can be you know
everything from your cell phone to gym
memberships to
um
um clothing whatever else that you spend
money on listed out
and then i want you to go back and put
dollar amounts next to each category and
your goal is for your income minus all
of those categories should equal zero
so every dollar of your income is
assigned you when that when that
paycheck hits you know exactly where
it's going
and there's something so diligent about
that and it's gonna take three months to
get it right so
so i'm just i'm warning everyone the
first month it's gonna be a disaster
okay and it was for me and my husband
like it's
you're gonna mess up you're gonna think
the light bill is one thing it's
something else the water is more this
but you know it's gonna be all over the
place
by the second month it gets a little bit
better and by the third month it starts
working so stick with it do not give up
and there's something so wonderful like
again that five six months after doing
this
it's like you have peace and you're like
oh my gosh i know exactly what i'm doing
with my income um and in that too
obviously if you have debt you're gonna
list your debt payments all of that so
that's all in the budget everything that
you spend money on now getting out of
debt that's a whole other topic here so
the first thing you want to do is save a
thousand dollars so when we go back to
the budgeting conversation put a savings
category under giving if you're in this
and i want you to put money away i want
you to give save then spend
so if you need to save a thousand
dollars for your emergency fund so find
a thousand dollars and you can do it in
your budget even by cutting out things
that you don't need like out to eat or
clothes like things that are not
essential cut the cable i mean like drop
memberships that you have that you're
not using like whatever you can squeeze
money out of that budget
to find a thousand dollars quickly so
that getting out of debt that's your
first step and and before you keep going
i think that's so helpful to mention
because a lot of times you're like look
i have my budget i have no room to save
a thousand dollars but there are ways
that you can cut and yes it might be
uncomfortable in the beginning but know
that it's not forever this is not
something that you're going to have to
do forever it's that short-term hard
work and sacrifice for the long-term
reward and gain that i have found just
so maximum beneficial to your life that
it might feel hard to cut that coffee
out to cut the gym membership even the
cable for a while just so that you can
get that fulfilled in that savings
account that you're talking about and i
love what you said about the giving
because it's so true starting from the
beginning before you you're like oh one
day when i make more then i'll give no
start from the beginning even if you
don't have very much you might be like
okay i'm going to donate even 50 to
someone in my community a single mom in
my community or someone who is on the
street as you're walking in the grocery
store that needs a meal and buy them a
meal and you know that you have that
every month to donate and you don't have
to be like donating to some huge
organization that you don't maybe at the
time have your income budget for because
you're like i only make such a little
amount there's no way i can spare it but
even that little amount it really does
go a long way and helps get you in that
habit
absolutely yes yes yes and yes to all of
that i mean it is it's so powerful it
really is and and your budget really is
that road map then to help you
do the things that you want to do right
and gives you that permission to say
okay i have that 50
budget of forgiving i gotta give 50
bucks somewhere this month you know it
kind of forces you to do it which is
awesome um so once that thousand dollars
is saved then you're gonna start working
your way out of debt and again that
thousand dollars could come from our
savings you already have you may already
have that thousand i don't care or maybe
you don't and you're like no i gotta
find it that's where you cut in the
budget or even earn extra income for a
short period of time
and then you're gonna start getting out
of debt so we teach the debt snowball
method there's kind of two ways to get
out of debt some people say the debt
avalanche which is you pay off the
highest interest rate first and we teach
the opposite which is the debt snowball
where you actually pay off the smallest
debt amount first
because back what we talked about
earlier in this podcast like you know
personal finance is not always just
about math so paying off the highest
interest rate yeah mathematically that
makes sense
but if we were doing math we wouldn't be
in credit card debt in the first place
right so it's not about math it is
really about getting those quick wins
there's something about that human
spirit
that has to be ignited especially if
you're someone that's really stressed
right now you're someone that's been in
the habit of paycheck to paycheck you're
someone that thinks there's no way
there's no way that can be me that you
have got to have an injection of hope
like you have to have a thing that says
i can do this yeah oh my gosh i can do
this and even paying off you know even
if it's a credit card and it has a 600
balance on it that you've kind of been
carrying around i don't care what it is
that smallest debt you put everything
towards it you pay that off as fast as
possible you're gonna be minimum
payments on everything because you're
gonna list out all of your debts
smallest to largest
stay current pay minimum payments on
everything but man that smallest debt
you are going to go after it and talk
about sacrifice you know you're still
going to be cutting the cable you're
still going to be saying no to vacation
you're doing nothing but focusing on
that smallest debt and then what's
powerful is once that's paid off you
take everything you're doing to that
smallest and you roll it over to the
second smallest once that's paid off you
have the payments you were going to pay
on the smallest and the second smallest
that's freed up so you have extra money
now to throw at the third and you keep
going and going going it's called the
debt snowball and so it's powerful we
find people are getting completely out
of debt except for their house in 18 to
24 months
wow and there's something addicting like
when you start winning and you start to
actually see that hope and you see that
light at the end of the tunnel and
you're like
oh my gosh like we're actually doing
this like we are we're doing this i mean
it just it gives fuel on the fire
to your spirit i mean there's something
about it that just keeps you so
motivated and so it's a time of
sacrifice like you said i love what you
said about it because it's so true it's
going to be hard you're going to be
saying no when you want to say yes all
of it but it's for a short period of
time we we stay at ramsey solutions to
live like no one else because no one's
doing that no one is living at that
sacrificial level much anymore you live
like no one else so later you can live
and give like no one else i love you
don't have payments
you are you are in the you know the 20
of america who's not paycheck to
paycheck i mean you're in a small
percentage of that point where you're
like wow i have no debt and it's it's
powerful what happens
um when you don't owe anyone anything
it's so powerful and i love the snowball
version because i myself even when it
comes to like to-do lists i have my long
to-do list i get my littlest things done
first because there's just something so
rewarding about checking things off and
knowing that i'm actually accomplishing
something even if it's the tiniest thing
and it's so true i actually have friends
in our life who were at one point living
paycheck to paycheck spending all of
their money buying um gadgets and gears
and things that whenever they had the
money they'd be like what new nice thing
can i buy a surfboard or nice new this
or that whatever all these things but
then they found themselves in a place
where they couldn't buy a house because
they weren't even close to having any
kind of savings um to buy a house they
weren't even close because they had debt
as well from the credit cards and once
they read dave ramsey's book total money
makeover and they started doing that
snowball effect paying it off it was
addicting it was like this feels so good
i'm getting it done and i'm selling my
camera i'm selling i'm selling my
surfboard i'm selling and they're
finding ways to sell the stuff that they
already bought and then they were able
to pay off and pay off that before you
know it debt free and they eventually
bought a beautiful home and they're like
wow this like life something that we
thought we could never get to because
they they weren't even actually making a
super high income but because it's the
mindset around money when you have your
money you spend it instead of
what you're saying the snowball effect
of paying it off and it's really
exciting and something that most people
aren't doing i love that and i love that
you added even the sell the stuff to get
that dollar emergency funder to pay off
debt i mean it's amazing how much stuff
we just have in our house that we don't
use you know so i'm like if there's a tv
on the wall take it off and set like do
whatever you can like sell it all
because you can get it later you can
always buy things again later but just
to get you out of this cycle you kind of
have to do these things that give like a
kind of a punch to your reality
and there's something powerful about it
when you're like man there's all this
stuff laying around that we just don't
use like get sell it get rid of it make
some cash throw it at the debt and all
of it so i love that that's such an
encouraging story to hear about your
friends yeah for sure and i think people
might be like well why would i sell it
if i'm just gonna buy it back later like
i think maybe kind of explain the
difference between whether like using
credit cards and getting a debt versus
like being able to pay cash for
something you know that you have the
money for yes yeah the credit card um
argument i feel like or whatever it is
it's it's a it's a big one because
credit cards i mean the fact that i've
never had one people are like what how
are you breathing air in our world today
without a credit card
and i mean study after study shows that
you spend more up to even 18 to 20
percent more when you use a credit card
than versus a debit card or cash wow
there's something emotional that happens
at a transaction when you spend money
that's not yours you end up spending
more
and then what happens again is this idea
of okay well i'm
um you know this feels good and this is
great i'll pay for it later i'll worry
about it later versus saying okay i'm
gonna say either save up or actually
spend my own money
to buy something and when you're living
your life i think kind of in that credit
card cycle it's like you're
you're living your life in the rearview
mirror i mean you are getting your
paycheck and paying for things in the
past like you're sitting there paying
for meals you've eaten
you know vacations you've taken movies
you've watched whatever it is
versus when it's your own money you pay
for it it's done like you're not
thinking about it again and when you get
your paycheck you're looking to the
future right even that budget that we
talk about you're budging for next month
you're looking to your future and you
just make different decisions your
mindset is completely different when
you're looking to the future versus the
past
and i'll add this not everyone agrees
with this but i feel it because i think
i just hate credit cards so much i've
just seen the damage that it does to
people buying stuff you know that they
don't always need or they depend on them
for their life and their bills versus
saying hey what do i do stretching
yourself to say is there another job
that i should take to make more income
where can i lower my expenses um so i
just see the credit card industry and
i'm like ugh and for me you know people
are like well i get it for the miles or
the points you know they kind of play
that game
and to me i'm like you know they're not
these companies that are extremely
generous and they're like here we would
love to give you this stuff they make
billions of dollars off of people
that don't pay theirs off every month
and that paying interest and paying late
fees and everything else because they're
mismanaging their money so to me i'm
like i don't want to take a benefit
because someone else a lot of people
around america are mismanaging their
money and now i benefit from that
you know situation and that system like
the whole thing is just kind of gross to
me so i'm like listen i'll save up and
pay for my southwest
ticket wherever i'm going like they're
you know i'm i'm i just don't play the
game so a lot of people are like well i
paid off every month the 42 of americans
don't pay it off every month
and now a word from our sponsors
guys i am obsessed with bite toothpaste
bits most commercial toothpastes are
filled with harsh chemicals artificial
flavors and preservatives which is not
something you want to be putting in your
mouth let alone eating because we
swallow five to seven percent of our
toothpaste every time we brush our teeth
bite makes toothpaste tablets made with
clean ingredients that are sulfate palm
oil and glycerin free and on top of that
the jars are so pretty it comes in
refillable glass jars and they send
refills and compostable pouches so
they're better for our bodies and our
earth no more plastic toothpaste tubes
bite toothpaste bits are so convenient
you just pop a bit in your mouth chew it
up and start brushing it will turn into
paste just like you're used to but with
no plastic tube or messy paste which
makes it extra convenient for kids who
think popping a bite in their mouth is
so fun and makes tooth brushing time a
pleasant experience it honestly felt a
little weird at first but now my whole
family is obsessed it's so effective and
makes my teeth extremely clean i ran out
of bite toothpastes once so i went back
to my old regular toothpaste and very
quickly i realized that my teeth didn't
feel as clean so i'm never going back to
pace and will be using bite from here on
out and my holistic dentist fully
approves bite makes plastic free
alternatives for everything on your
bathroom sink so you can cut out the
harsh chemicals and plastic waste
without compromise and bite is offering
my listeners 20 off your first order go
to
trybite.com ellen or use the code ellen
at checkout to claim this deal that's
t-r-y-b-i-t-e
dot com slash ellen we're also brought
to you today by buffy buffy makes
betting that is not only incredibly soft
and cozy but also sustainable the
bedding industry typically has a huge
impact on the environment but buffy
decided to change that their products
are made using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed their debut product the cloud
comforter is covered in super soft
eucalyptus fabric and filled with fluffy
fiber made from 100 recycled bottles
eucalyptus uses 10 times less water than
cotton to grow and its fiber is produced
using recyclable earth-friendly solvents
this comforter has over 18 000 five-star
reviews customers agree is the softest
fluffiest comforter they've ever tried
it keeps you at the perfect temperature
so you feel cozy without overheating and
is by far my favorite comforter i've
ever slept with it's hypoallergenic and
machine washable thanks to an innovative
stitching pattern that keeps its fluffy
fill in place the best part for me
though is that the average down
comforter harms 12 geese but buffy's
comforter is cruelty free it feels even
softer than down while keeping
approximately 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans purchasing your
sheets and comforter from buffy is a
great investment because their products
last such a long time that you aren't
wasting money buying sheets over and
over again so use my code ellen for 20
off orders over 80
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free if you don't love it return it
at no cost
so yeah i'm just really disciplined in
it that i'm like i just want nothing to
do with debt like i've not seen it help
people for me i will save up and we'll
i'll spend my money um but the the
credit card thing it's a it's for sure a
big one but you can you can rent a car
have an apartment you can do things
without a credit card sometimes it's a
little bit more inconvenient you kind of
have to go around a system or two and
maybe fill out an extra paper or
whatever it is but for the mo i mean
i've never had an issue we travel and we
buy off amazon and we do the everything
everyone else does yeah but it's just
with our money
that's such a good point i mean
the thing about how it's a little more
inconvenient maybe it wouldn't be as
inconvenient more people didn't have a
credit card
um
if maybe maybe your maybe your trend
your um your passion will grow and it'll
become a trend and then you'll have to
yeah and then it wouldn't be so hard um
but i have always had that mindset of
of what you're saying about for the
miles and we do have a credit card but
like we said we always pay it off and i
i've always been like oh well you know
like for a lot of people they really
need to not have a credit card if they
struggle with that you know handing a
card over and it having the mindset of
it's not my money type thing and so i've
never felt that way so it was like oh
maybe it's you know it's different but i
really like the way that you're
explaining it because we always pay it
off every month and it's like well
that's good enough then we get the miles
but the thing about the the miles
basically being money from other people
who are struggling and who are just
paying their month to month and that is
kind of icky that is kind of icky that
aspect and then the thing you were
saying about how you spend more
um subconsciously even though you know
like because for me when i look at a
credit card i i don't look at it as a
credit card because we do pay it off
every month it just looks like my debit
card but maybe there's a subconscious
level where if i'm not handing cash i'm
more likely to pick up like something
more expensive at the grocery store or a
few other things because i'm not maybe
thinking about the price as much as if
it was like cash in hand so those are
all really good points i'm might need to
talk to my husband cancel our yeah let's
see i'll we'll see ellen you can send me
a text let me i'll give you an update
we've always only had one but yeah yeah
i had a friend and
he was like super hardcore on this stuff
like we are and it's funny because a few
years ago we were having dinner and he
was like guys i gotta confess i got a
southwest credit card and i was like
fine like we can still be friends it's
not like this like salvation issue of
friendship or something like it's fine
um i don't agree you know i don't and
don't necessarily live that way but you
know we can obviously still be friends
and he was laughing and then about three
months later we like hung out with him
again and and he was like guys i got rid
of it and i was like that was fast yeah
i know he was like well i realized and
he told a story about taking his sons to
a sporting goods store because they
needed jerseys for school it was like
you know favorite athlete day or where
your team's color or whatever it is
and he was like and i found myself being
like oh no get those jerseys because
they look a little bit nicer you know
they're only 15 20 bucks more and here
grab the hat like he was like i was
subconsciously
like picking up more things than i
probably would have if i had just my
debit card like oh no that jersey's fine
so anyways hearing him say that i was
like that's so interesting so it you see
it play out in your life of gosh if it
really was just my debit card would i
make different decisions yeah i would
argue yes but that's interesting and
maybe even better if it was cash but i
know cash is like such i know the cash
is the ultimate because that that does
show it triggers
the pain centers of your brain they've
done mri studies on it and literally the
pain centers of your brain light up when
you let go of actual physical cash so
like oh my gosh there's a big difference
yes even versus plastic even with the
debit card you know what's coming out of
your account so it's a little different
but that physical cash but i know it's
becoming like a dying trend yeah it's
like i do tell people yeah
that when they are first budgeting to
cash out maybe two or three categories
in their budget that they tend to
overspend on for just like a month or
two and use actual cash
uh like for that the grocery or
something at the grocery store
and yeah and it's and it's it's an
interesting experiment because it kind
of keeps you accountable to the budget
and also there's that element of
oh gosh i'm seeing my money physically
yes
yes those are all really good points and
even though my husband and i are not in
debt and we still have our financial
goals and so totally we could cut in
certain areas and so that that's all
really interesting so my next question
then did we finish like the phases you
said the savings yes yes baby yep so
yeah we have the seven baby steps so
that baby step one is a thousand dollar
emergency fund baby step two is becoming
completely debt free except for your
house so the debt snowball awesome yeah
that's so inspiring and i've witnessed
it firsthand from so many people who've
followed those types of steps and it is
addicting and exciting it's very
exciting and freeing oh my gosh so free
so what are some things that people
waste their money on that they think
they need
oh gosh a lot of things
you know we're kind of in a and i think
the pandemic
you know fast forwarded this
but the memberships the subscriptions
have like
every everything now is a subscription
right and so
uh i get in the habit of this too where
i'm like oh there's a show we want to
watch so we'll pay for it and then i
forget about it and we're paying for it
for like two or three months after we're
done with the show and i'm like oh gosh
like we're we've kept it you know it's
these auto draft type of situations
whether it's a app on your phone
to
um subscriptions on the tv to
memberships that you go you know we have
kids and so it's there's so many of
these you know indoor trampoline parks
or like these random places and like
well for 19.99 a month you could have
four visits for you know and i'm like oh
that's a great deal so i'm a i mean i'm
like oh that sounds good so i'll sign up
and then i look up three months later
and i'm like we've never we haven't been
back like oh my god i've paid for this
so so that membership subscription model
uh is very beneficial to the companies
uh and so and if you use it then it can
be a good deal but man we can rack up
those so easily
i would say that i would say there's a
level even with our with our food
that we you know can tend to where we
buy our food and the specific grocery
stores even price differs dramatically
and so looking to say okay where can you
even grocery shop to help cut the budget
um because you don't always have to shop
at the nicest nicest nicest place there
are still
great products at other stores uh you
know all day for instance i think about
all day and they have great options and
it's very inexpensive
um you know that's a that's an example
so i would say that
um you know i would look to even the am
i i'm a sucker for this too but it's the
amazon purchases or oh yeah we need this
we need that and this idea that you can
just order things so quickly and they
just show up
we can kind of get in the cycle of oh
yeah oh gosh we yeah we do need that
here grab that that that that and you
know we needed scissors the other day
it's just like example but you know and
i went on amazon and bought like a six
pack of scissors i was like yeah we
didn't need six scissors like we needed
two but why did i like just add it
because i was like oh it's not that much
more i literally just did the same thing
i literally just did the same thing with
nail clippers because i did like i
didn't want to go the store i wasn't
going to go to the store for a while and
so i on amazon it was like a four pack
of nail clippers and i literally
couldn't even find a single nail flipper
to order so i was like i guess i'll get
the four pack
i know i know so yeah those those little
purchases that i think you know they
really can't they can add up so i would
look at that um you know one big thing i
would say for people to save a lot of
money on and you still need it um but
insurance so there's a lot of insurances
that you don't need you know there's you
know i think of accidental death
insurance you know there's like these
kind of random insurances that you
really don't need but the ones you do
need health insurance life insurance
homeowners insurance car insurance all
of that
re-look at those things because those
are types of things in our financial
life that we just
we get one day and then we just keep
paying it
and it's years and years and years until
we re-look at the policies and you
actually could save a lot of money
because you might be overpaying for
those things so yeah so it's kind of it
runs the gamut of things that i feel
like we can kind of semi-waste
uh that we don't need but it adds up
that's right yeah and i always kind of
look at like what is the most important
to you so that doesn't mean all these
like anyone's listening is like oh man i
gotta cut everywhere for all these
categories we're all talking about but
really it really comes down to what's
the most important to you and then in
other areas where can you sacrifice and
that's how andrew and i live even when
we were budgeting really really tight
when we first had moved to hawaii and
we're living in like the
junkiest cheapest rent that we could
find and the cheapest car and him
working a lot we still really valued
getting the highest quality food that we
could get so we would buy the expensive
produce from the farmers market the
organic produce because that was like a
really important value for us is getting
really healthy food but that doesn't
mean that we're just like oh in food
category just spend whatever we want
we're like intentional with it and like
you said not every grocery store is the
best place to get those things so
there's actually like three different
grocery stores on the island that are
kind of like health stores and instead
of just buying everything at the one
store my husband who's very good with
being aware of prices and money he'll
make sure to get the celery and the
apples at this store and we know that
this store has a cheaper version of of
the rice pasta and this store has
cheaper beans and and in regards to that
like paying attention to that because it
does cut a lot because i used to do the
grocery shopping and he's like you're
done ellen you wasted so much money i'm
doing the shopping because he pays
attention to the prices yes and i think
you get to a point that you've paid the
price that like you know if you are out
of debt you have your emergency fund
your funding like you're doing the
things you know there is a point though
yeah convenience you pay more for the
convenience of staying at one grocery
store um for it but yeah especially if
the people that are you're saving up for
that emergency fund or you're getting
out of debt oh look around look i mean
seriously look at the prices it's
amazing the difference i mean even three
dollars on what item
over time and you multiply that by 20 30
items i'm like it makes a huge
difference yeah or you might even be
yeah you might even be just be
used to always buying the red bell
peppers like you always buy the organic
red bell peppers but then if you're not
paying attention to the price maybe two
weeks later it's gonna be five dollars a
pound and whereas like if you would have
got that if you get just wait and get a
different vegetable now and then get the
bell peppers two weeks from now they
might be two dollars a pound and looking
at the sales it's actually that's better
for your health anyways to get a variety
of your plant sources but yeah so i
think all that to say is that there are
certain things that might be really
valuable to you and that doesn't mean
you have to cut out everything so
looking at even your memberships like
okay these two memberships are really
maybe even adding value to my life like
uh something that's helping you with
your fitness or your mindset or some
kind of membership that's really helpful
but all these other ones i'm kind of
wasting money on and i don't need so
just being aware and it doesn't have to
be so like oh i gotta sacrifice
everything yeah yes exactly go through
and just take an inventory of what's
going on because you may even be paying
for things that you're not using at all
so for sure you can cut that
okay so the next question i have is what
about for people who are
really struggling financially like a
single parent or someone living on like
a really low fixed income someone who
can barely pay their rent um
and they're just or they're just
swimming in debt maybe that on top of it
all together is this topic of getting
out of debt and building wealth or
becoming financially independent like
only for the privileged or what is your
what's your thoughts on that for people
who are like really struggling maybe
they're listening to this or maybe they
know someone who and someone's listening
to this and they're like yeah but i know
someone who is really struggling like
they can't just they don't they're not
paying for a membership they're not
paying for even coffee and they don't
really have places to cut what are your
thoughts on that
well this morning actually we have an
all staff meeting that we do as a
company and they played a clip from the
radio show of a debt-free caller and she
was 72 from west virginia
and in 36 months she paid off 20
thousand dollars making 19 000 a year
she was on social security and had a
pension wow and she paid off that debt
and so i look at her and like if she can
do it anyone can and so i would say
no matter who you are no matter what age
you are what amount of debt you have
your income level
you have the ability to decide what
you're going to do and so really you
want to look at money that it flows two
ways money flows in and money flows out
and so money flowing in is your income
and so to relook at it honestly and just
say okay here's my job here's what they
pay me
is there just think outside the box
again it may be uncomfortable just think
outside the box is there something else
for the time being
that i can do extra maybe pick up some
extra work maybe on a weekend or or
maybe two weeks or two nights a week
whatever it looks like that's feasible
for you that you're able to say okay i
can do a little bit more here and bring
in any extra or even your your job that
you have maybe it's three part-time jobs
that you're working together to create a
full-time income
i don't know what the situation is but
look at that income and say is there a
different
uh career path is there even asking for
a raise going in to your to your leader
and saying at work hey
you know what does it look like for me
to be on a growth track here to to help
more around but to be able to bring
value and you know receive something in
return for that because i really i want
to work hard i want to make more you
know whatever the whatever the situation
is but that inflow is one way money
flows so you need to really look at that
income so whether it's extra job that
you take on for a period of time just to
get your head above water um or maybe
changing jobs completely whatever it
looks like to to see what that what you
can do there and then the other end of
the equation is the outflow so this is
your expenses so looking to see okay
where am where is my money going what
does this look like and and when you do
the budget you know even housing we
recommend that you should have no more
than 25 of your take-home pay 25 to 30
percent go towards rent or your mortgage
so you may look up and say wow our
mortgage is
48 of
my income like half of my money is going
to where i'm living
then you have too much house at that
point you know or your more or your rent
is too expensive and even cutting
something like that back which again i
know is so uncomfortable and it sounds
like so much work but even say okay well
what if we move to a different type of
apartment and we oh and it's not our
favorite it's not what we want but it
gets down to that range of hey okay now
we have freed up 25 more of our income
just by that move you know looking at
the sweeping view is really important
and for some people too i would
encourage them you know once you look at
your income and your outgo
um to know that this is a journey and
for some people it's going to take them
a little bit longer for some people it's
going to be shorter i mean i don't know
what the circumstances are but um but
it's amazing to know that like
it's a marathon it's not a sprint and we
live in a world again that we want
results so quickly and to know for
whatever situation you're in because not
everyone starts at the same starting
line unfortunately you know in our world
um that you may be one of those that's
like man i i've had setback after step
back after setback
but the belief in the hope ellen i think
is the key that no matter who you are
to know i get to wake up every day and i
get to make a decision with my life
because when other people have your
destiny in their hands whether that's
corporate america or the government
you're depending on other people to take
care of you
that's when things start to get lost but
when you really have the belief that i
have the ability
to do something different with my life
and i have the ability to make decisions
that can change my life forever you put
the power back in your hands
and that does something to people where
they say i can do this and that lady
that i was talking about earlier that 72
year old from west virginia she did i
mean she that's what she said she had
been in debt her whole life
her entire life and four years ago her
daughter was sick and she couldn't get
to wisconsin where her daughter was she
had no money she had no savings and
nothing she was a single mom her whole
life and raised two girls and and she
got to the point she was like i'm done
and so and again it took her 36 months
took a long time for her to pay off that
20 grand but she decided and so
you know we hear stories from that from
you know even deeper you know six
figures of student loan debt we hear
from people i mean all it runs the gamut
but the one consistent theme is they
keep saying i believe that i could do
this
yeah i love that that's really really
powerful because a lot of times we can
very easily try to look at other people
and be like oh well i would never be
able to get out of debt like they have i
wouldn't i don't have the finances to
even come close to cutting things i
don't even have subscriptions that they
are cutting but you have to we have to
stop comparing and look at our own life
and be like okay where can i
grow even if it's baby steps even if
it's smaller and even if i'm not going
to like make this transformation as fast
as maybe somebody else it's like your
own personal growth that's going to make
the hugest difference when you're just
focusing on what you can do so i love
that message
that's right yeah it's it's amazing
again that's what i kind of love about
money is
it's not just the dollars and cents that
we talk about and the math like there's
something empowering um to a person when
you say like you can do this
you have the ability to do this and and
i do and i believe that after 12 years
of doing this
job i've heard again every story
imaginable so i have hope for whoever's
listening out there that i
1000 here that it's hard and again for
some people they've been dealt a hand
that is really really difficult
but when you if you keep doing what
you've been doing you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting and so
there's a moment that you have to say
i'm done i'm done i'm done i'm done i'm
changing course i'm doing something
different and then you're gonna start to
see results yeah and i mean you could
even look at your dad coming from being
declaring bankruptcy
to taking charge of his life and
completely transforming that to where he
is now that doesn't mean everybody's
going to have that same trajectory but
it's just the just the understanding of
like the power of that that is within
your hands whatever power that is in
your control to be able to work with
that and it also is helpful inspiring
for anyone who's not in that situation
to be able to give to that like giving
to your local community it doesn't have
to again be like a big organization but
if you know someone who's in need if you
have that ability to help someone out in
that situation
yeah i love that okay so can we talk a
little bit about the importance of
saving and how few people are prepared
to pay off for an emergency pay
something off for an emergency
yes the savings
emergency idea is so important i really
look at this as
your safety net between you and life and
so having money
in
in a savings account is so so important
that's why that thousand dollars before
you start getting out of debt is key
because if something happens i don't
want you going back into debt
to solve that emergency i want that
money there to be there to catch you and
say okay here i can put this money
towards the flat tire or whatever is
going on
and then once you pay off all of your
debts then you're gonna save up three to
six months worth of expenses and so when
you do this i want you to look at this
amount of money
as insurance it's not an investment so
people will hear
oh my gosh that's a big dollar amount
just to be sitting but that's the
purpose it's just to sit it's just to be
there it's your cushion if something
happens again
a job loss or a health crisis you just
have money and so getting a little
tactical but you can put this in a
traditional savings account you can put
this in a money market account but i
don't want you to invest it this is just
for emergencies and that's our baby step
three so again one is that thousand
dollars two is the debt snowball and
three is the fully funded emergency fund
and something happens ellen after i talk
to people after that baby step three
things just like the countenance of the
their lives just change where they're
like oh my gosh
i have no debt
and i have a pile of money in the bank
for just in case something happens like
you know
it's gonna probably happen life happens
so you may have to dip into it for sure
but
there's something that suddenly you have
options and you have choices with your
life you know you're in that job that
you've hated
and now you you have the freedom to go
and do something different if you want
you know you've you've been wanting to
to go on that vacation and you have the
ability to do that like there's just
such freedom that comes with having that
savings there uh and it's not if
something were to happen it's when i
mean life is gonna happen we went
through a pandemic for two years who
knew you know like stuff is going to
happen and having that money and that
safety net is key and then once you have
that then we move on to baby step four
which is saving for retirement so this
is a little bit more of that future
saving mindset but this is saving 15 of
your income into retirement so whether
it's a 401k a roth ira
but looking at retirement say okay i'm
going to put money away for that for the
long term
which is really really important because
it obviously gets here faster than we
all we all probably wanted to but but
being prepared for it is is huge
that's awesome yeah that's that's really
inspiring because like you said if you
don't have anything at the bank you're
kind of at this will of like anything
something could happen and i have no way
to cover it and it kind of makes me
think of in other areas like something
you brought up earlier about relying on
the government or relying on you know
other people in some way to take care of
you so what do you think then about like
student loans and people kind of waiting
for their student loans to be forgiven
and the opposite which is kind of like
taking charge of your life like let's
can you talk about that a little bit
yeah for sure you know the student loan
conversation it's an interesting one i
think there's like a major underbelly of
that whole industry that i'm like oh i
hate it because
you can still go to school debt-free
it's school choice is huge staying
in-state or going to a community college
scholarships and grants and working like
these things you can still go to school
debt-free but we believe this lie that
you have to have loans to go to school
and so what's happened now is we've
gotten to this point right trillions of
dollars of student loan debt and so you
know it's important i i my heart is so
torn on it ellen too because i'm like
there's there is a part of me that's
like hey
you signed your name to something
there's a level of personal
responsibility and other people have
paid off their loans and is it kind of
fair to them for yourself to be
forgiving right there's like that
element but there's also the heart of me
i'm like they were 18
18 years old when they signed basically
their financial life away some of them
six figures
and some of them don't even know like
they're filling out the fafsa and they
thought that it was a grant
or a scholarship and it was loans but no
one told that like they didn't know
so that whole industry i just hate so
much and my heart breaks for it because
i think there's that level too so i'm a
little bit i'm torn on it but but where
i am really sure is that i would not
wait around on washington dc to fix your
issues and that's not a republican or
democratic thing i mean i wouldn't wait
on trump i wouldn't wait i'm biting i
won't wait
no wait on anyone like have the ability
to say i'm gonna do this because they've
been talking about student loan
forgiveness and biden came out recently
about some you know i think it was um i
think it was i think it was 6 billion
that he was going to forgive but it's
not even in the budget the annual budget
like like you know what i mean like we
hear these things and the hope is like
okay
but you're going to be waiting a long
time and so again no matter how you got
in whether you're 18 and no one told you
and you kind of were victim to the
to the system and you got put in that or
you knew but you just wanted to go to
that school you couldn't afford and now
you want to you know i don't care what
side you're on on it
i still think that you have the ability
to pay it off and so
now when they've stopped where you don't
have to be paying your payments and
interest is not accumulating now is the
time to pay it off because you're
actually attacking the principal
of the debt and there's no interest
right now so i am a huge believer in not
waiting around on washington dc i think
we're waiting a really long time and
that you have the ability to do it like
you could actually become debt-free
before the next election right i'm like
you could do this like you can pay off
your loans
yes totally and i mean that's even just
opens up the conversation of college and
if everybody needs to be going to
college anyways you know
yeah because a lot of times there's like
this pressure that maybe we might have
experienced from our parents who
they experienced so much benefit from
going to college because way back then
it was actually more valuable for a lot
of different careers to go to college
and not as many people are doing
we're going to it but it's a different
world today and not everybody needs to
go to college i was going to say the roi
on the investment a lot of times is not
worth it like people are going going to
these schools that are even
private universities that i'm sure are
great schools but you're going you know
thirty thousand dollars forty sixty
thousand dollars a year
a year on tuition to get a degree in
english
and then you grab you know what i'm
saying like i'm like there's not roi and
it's like we've become stupid about
education which is such a
obviously it's crazy so i'm like
look at the situation and and i think
you know higher education is great and
if you have the ability and you say hey
i really want a degree there's a way to
do it and do it really wisely but
looking at the roi and you're right
there's some fields i'm like you may not
even have to go
so i think turning the tables i think is
huge on that college discussion because
the tuition has just skyrocketed
it's insane because they know they can
because students just keep taking out
the loans and so yeah i think the whole
discussion needs to be had around it
yeah and just taking the pressure off
where a lot of times people graduate
high school and they're like i don't
even know what i want to do but i guess
i'll go to college and i'll just which
is kind of what i did it was like
there's you know pressures to go to
college i'm like i guess i'll study
business you know because i don't know
what i'm going to do but i'm like
looking back i'm like the job i do now i
definitely didn't need a business degree
like a lot of it comes with learning
through actually experiencing it or just
your natural head space with it um or
something that you could do through an
apprenticeship as opposed to spending so
much money on college and so it depends
if you want to go do like a specific job
that needs a degree of course like right
you want to be a doctor amazing
but not everybody needs to go to college
and you can save a lot of money for that
absolutely amen sister amen it's crazy
it's wild it's it's been a it's a wild
industry yeah right and it's always
changing too like our children when
they're in college like college age is
going to be totally different as well so
we don't even know what it's going to be
like with
college and everything and that also
makes me think of another thing that we
didn't really talk on that much about
ways that we can save money and avoid
spending so much is like cars can you
talk a little bit about how much how
often we're spending more for cars than
we necessarily need to especially if we
need to be on a budget or have debt
yes absolutely yeah the
getting a car payment i think in my
viewpoint on debt i think it's the one
debt that kind of makes me cringe you
know like i like credit cards like the
student loans i'm like oh it's
frustrating but the card debt it just it
kills me because you're taking out a
loan and paying interest on something
that's going down in value now right now
the car industry is insane so i know
used cars have like spiked up and like i
mean it's it's crazy but that's the only
time in history that this has happened
it is usually a depreciating asset and
so when you take out a loan on something
that's going down in value it's just
it's not smart and when you invest a car
payment the average car payment on a new
car is over 500 it's 568 dollars wow and
if you invested
that car payment from age 18 to age
i think it was 75 maybe it's close to 4
million dollars whoa like that's what
your car payment is costing you over the
course of your life oh my god it's a car
it's a car so so i think we have kind of
gotten out of control you know our cars
have become like this status symbol you
know you kind of
what you drive is who you are all of
that and i'm not mad at nice cars i
think that it's fine to have a nice car
i always say it's okay to have nice
stuff
don't let your nice stuff have you oh my
gosh i should have you when it's your
identity that you're like i have to have
this thing to be happy or to be content
or to find joy this thing is going to do
that you're going to be a rat in a wheel
for the rest of your life nothing is
going to satisfy that and then number
two is that it can have you if you go
into debt for it because if you owe
you don't own it's not yours and it has
you at that point you're using your
paycheck again to not invest and build
wealth over time you're using it to
throw out a car payment so
i am all about yeah paying off your car
if you have a car payment i'm all about
paying cash
for cars going forward for your life
because uh there's something about it
you you change what you're looking for
when again when it's your money uh and
and your cars you know and i enjoy a
nice car so i'm like i i'm the one my
husband's way more utilitarian about it
i'm one i'm like oh i could i can
appreciate a nice suv like i can
appreciate a nice car you know but
really your car is to get you to point a
to point b right it's like that's
literally what it's for and so it's
become this
this other thing in our in our culture
and so it's it's it's taking people's
money is what's happening with car loans
so i'm all about paying off your car if
you cannot pay off your car within 18
months
you need to sell it if your car is more
than 50 of what you make per year you
need to sell it so those are kind of my
rules around it but other than that pay
it off have a paid for car
and your next car you can sell the
current car you have
save up some cash put it together and
step up to a nicer car you know i'm not
mad again getting a nice car but i want
you to do it with cash
right yeah and going back to the people
that i look at in my life growing up who
were really good with their money but
you would have no clue that they
actually had money they generally drove
really cheap cars like astro vans and i
even look back at the car that we got
when we first moved here and it was just
the things were sticky on the side i
don't know why the walls felt sticky but
the windows didn't work but you know
what we paid four thousand dollars for
it cash and it was like we didn't have a
car payment and just be knowing that
doesn't mean we're gonna have that car
forever but like you said if you could
invest that money that you would month
to month pay 500
um and instead invest it then down the
road you're gonna have more money to be
able to buy a nicer car later so it's
just like delaying that in that desire
for instant gratification that
i think is really helpful that most
people like nobody's talking about you
just hear you gotta have a nice car or
even leasing a car which is even worse
yeah leasing a car according to money
magazine it's the most expensive way to
finance a vehicle so the lease is like
no and then the car payment i'm like
nope so yeah paying cash for cars and
like you said i love that you pointed
out your first car because it may not be
a nice car people like wait what you
want to pay cash for car i don't have a
ton of money
it's gonna be a crappy car i'm like yeah
for a short period of time you're not
gonna live you're not gonna drive that
thing forever you're gonna drive it for
a short period of time so you can save
up and pay and upgrade
yes yes totally it's just i think it's
like this like novel idea that's like
what i didn't even know i could do that
you just kind of like everybody you go
to college you get this huge amount of
debt and it's taking you like you know
decades to pay it off and you have this
500 car payment for this nice car so
that like you kind of fit in with
everybody else around you
um but you don't have to do that you can
stick out and you know it doesn't really
matter if you have a cheap car right and
two i'm like you know if you're not a
car person like you're not gonna know
you know a i don't know even a bmw right
like you're not gonna know it or i
wouldn't a 2010
versus a brand new you know what i'm
saying like even if you go to like the
luxury end and you get a used one
most people don't know like like you're
fine you're fine yeah yeah and also just
about it yeah and also being able to
just keep it as long as you can because
it's like that's money you're saving by
not spending on a new car like
it's tempting to be like oh the new car
but like you know maybe reel it in
especially when you're trying to build
your wealth and stuff
yeah and so okay so once you get your
savings people are like all right now
what like how do you i guess they feel
intimidated maybe to like invest and
like where do you go from there
yes so that 15 of your income will go
into retirement and i would sit down
with the investment professional at this
point
um you know we have smart investor pros
all over the country that we recommend
so you can check them out or someone
else if you know someone that has a
great investment professional but
sitting down with someone that does this
day in and day out because they really
will help you look at your entire plan
and and kind of your whole
financial your goals and everything and
they'll help you
put money in some you know good funds
and i would say though with investing it
is intimidating so when you go in and
sit with someone don't feel stupid for
asking questions ask everything i do not
want you putting money into something
that you don't understand so you want to
know everything like to the point that
if you walked out of that office and i'm
standing on the sidewalk
you could recite back to me all right
here's what we're doing this is what
this is and like i mean i want you to
really know
um i think it's really important to be
educated in it so
so that would be for the investing and
then the same thing you know that's baby
step four so baby step five is saving
for kids college we kind of mentioned
about college but if you do have kids
you know maybe opening up a esa
educational savings account or a 529
putting some money in that so that when
they get to be college age if they want
to go to college there's some money
there if not you can actually pass on to
a sibling or even up to i think it's two
to three generations so you can keep
that account um and just let it sit
there maybe it's your grandkids that
will use it one day you know whatever it
is but i think planning for that is is
wise if you have the ability to
and then baby step six is paying off
your house from there uh paying off your
house early and then baby step seven is
the final baby step and that's just
where you continue to invest and you
continue to build wealth and become
extremely generous
so that's kind of the gamut of the baby
steps but yeah that um that's saving for
retirement it's a big one um yeah for
your life long term but sitting down
with someone is something i would really
recommend
i love that because i think you know
this conversation if we left it there it
could be like okay well i pay off the
debt and i'm driving a crappy car and i
don't have get to get my coffee or my
subscription but like looking at like
down the road what happens next and how
you're able to give generously and live
life differently and pay off your home
even sooner because that's just
something unfathomable for a lot of
people you just kind of think you know i
know people who have been paid in my
life like older people who are still
paying off their home like 30 40 years
like so so late right like so many years
down the road they're still paying it
off when if you spent your money in a
different way you would have been able
to pay it off earlier and then you have
that extra money every month to
potentially retire earlier and that's
another like
invaluable type of idea that we're kind
of sold like everything is always just
you retire at 70 years old and i don't
know about you but i would love to
retire before that
i know it'd be so great right no you
make a great point so those first three
baby steps
uh the emergency fund the getting out of
debt and the fully funded emergency fund
i kind of see those as like pedal to the
metal like you are sacrificing you're
not drinking the coffee you're driving
the crappy car like it is game on and
then once you do that and you move on to
retirement and kids college that's when
you get to say okay we can let our foot
off the gas
we can we can save up and replace the
car we can go on vacation you can start
to bring those things back in because
you actually have the money like if you
have no debt payments except for your
mortgage
you can do a lot of things right so um
so that ability yes from that saving for
retirement and beyond really does kind
of
you can relax put things back in the
budget and not be so sacrificial because
i don't want you to do that forever you
know
yeah that's not the plan our plan is to
get on the other side of it into it yeah
yeah because like the people that we're
talking about who are like not buying
the expensive cars later down the road
now they do have the nicer cars they're
living a little bit more in luxury and
it's like hey
dang like they don't have those
same type of um stressors in life now
that their kids are grown and it's like
we can just enjoy what we have and also
give generously so so why is giving
generously such an integral part to this
discussion in your opinion
oh gosh you know i think that there's
just there's something about when you
give and you live life with an open hand
there is a
there's a joy i think there's a peace
there's something that comes with
the idea that you're doing this not just
for you because i think we are consumers
right in our world and i'm like we can
consume and consume but after a while
like it's just stuff like it's not bad
but it just ends up being stuff and our
happiness our contentment our joy is not
wrapped in stuff and when you think it
is
and you buy something thinking oh if i
could just have that i'll be good you
get it and then there's gonna be an
upgrade there's gonna be a nicer thing
there's gonna there's always gonna
you're always gonna push the envelope
and if you just run that rat race
there is this level of joy that you just
don't experience and with giving
i think you experience it to the
fullness i mean there's just
there's just something awesome about
being able to say hey there's someone in
need there's an organization something
you're passionate about
you're like i'm able to help literally
change the world in a small small way
i'm doing something that's giving an
effect and giving hope to people and
i think it's amazing and again i see
money it's a tool like that's how i
really view it i'm like it's a tool
to create a life that i love and to
enjoy with my family but it is a tool to
help people and and i just see people
that just are consumers and they kind of
just
keep everything here and it reminds me
kind of of a pond
where my where water flows in but water
doesn't flow out
and on top of that pond is just like
scum you know what i mean like there's
no movements
stagnant and there's something about
flowing in the outflow of money of
giving that there's life to it there's
something there and and and i'll be
honest i'm a christian and so there's a
there's an essential part to serving and
giving that's even part of my faith that
something just comes alive in me when
i'm like i'm able to do that and it's
it's something that money can't buy
money can't buy that and the beautiful
thing is too you get to help more people
when you have more money and so by
getting out of debt and all of that
that's part of your for me it's part of
the why
of this journey to say i'm going to get
myself an order our household in order
so that there's overflow and um there's
just not a price to be put on that
yes oh totally and there is something so
amazing about coming to the end of your
month and be like i have this amount
that i've designated that i can give and
possibly over time be able to give more
and more and more and i can i can give
this to organizations and individual
people in your community
or organizations at large around the
world that can help other people it is
very amazing and i think something and
give to things that you're passionate
about right so this isn't just like
giving to this black hole of i don't
know whatever i'm doing it do it like
what's the thing that gets you like
what's the thing that man stirs in you
is it foster care is it is it adoption
is it is it human trafficking and
helping people getting rescued like
what's that thing that man you just
can't
you just want to do something about you
know when you give to that and you're
part of that you're like my money is is
literally helping funds x y and z and
get involved in it i mean all of it i
think it's just
yeah it's just something money doesn't
buy it's amazing there's something about
that life-giving of being generous and
having that intention with your
whole mindset around money from getting
out of debt and everything like that
actually the next organization i'm um or
the next person i'm interviewing for the
podcast is our rescue from timbalara do
you know him for human trafficking i
don't know if you know but yes no i've
heard yes
i don't know him personally but yeah but
yeah that's like the next person i'm
interviewing speaking of human
trafficking so that's crazy oh my gosh
that's so funny that you're doing the
work yeah okay that's so inspiring i
love that the way that i see that you
and dave ramsey will like talk about
giving and it it just changes the whole
conversation around money rather than it
being just like very inward and selfish
it's like outward and giving and that's
beautiful okay so i only have a couple
more questions um i thought it would be
fun to talk a little about like teaching
kids about healthy finances um because a
lot of my audience are parents and what
way do you go about it what do you
recommend for
teaching children you know healthy
habits with finances
for sure yes i love this conversation
because i think it's i think it's so key
and it doesn't have to be complicated
you know a lot of parents are like oh my
gosh how do i even do this and i'm like
listen keep it simple keep it
age-appropriate and just remember work
give save spends it's four things that's
really all they need to know they need
to know that money comes from work
money doesn't just come from mom and
dad's you know back pocket it's it comes
from working and so even rewarding them
on you know having a few chores around
the house that they can do
that you that you pay them and you're
like hey if you do this i'll pay you a
dollar whatever the amount is whatever
it looks like for your family but to
kind of make that tie as early as
possible that that's where money comes
from now they're not gonna get paid on
everything i think there's part of it
that you're part of the family and
you're gonna you're gonna do it and
sorry that's that's part of this
household yeah uh but but you miss some
teaching opportunities when you don't
pay on any on something like i think
there is a beauty in them earning money
because then you're going to teach them
once they earn that money to give
save and spend in that order
so letting them be part of this giving
conversation that we've been talking
about like having a small part in that
or maybe there's something that they
love that they want to give to so having
some money to give have them save for
something let them have a picture or
something that they're looking towards
and it could be a barbie it could be
pokemon cards like whatever it is but
that they're kind of saving up for so
they're learning that delayed
gratification and then the spending
letting them enjoy and they're going to
learn great lessons from that they're
going to feel rewarded that they get to
buy the thing they wanted and all of it
so those four principles look different
per age but i think implementing that
age-appropriately is really really
important and they kind of just get that
feel and again
you don't have to have this like money
summit you know that you feel like you
have to just teach them everything as
life happens bring them in like bring
them in and show them hey
here's what a mutual fund looks like
like like let's like let's look at
numbers if you're comfortable doing that
and showing them compound interest when
they can understand math um you know if
you're at the grocery store and you're
buying not buying the the red bell
pepper because it's five dollars that
wasn't like saying it to them be like
hey
you know you know last time mom got this
but we're not gonna get it a little bit
more like these little things they pick
up on kids they do
they know and they're learning and
they're absorbing everything and so more
is caught than taught
so i will say that your example as the
parent
is going to teach them far more than if
you're sitting down and trying to
explain what a mutual fund is like you
living this stuff out
they're going to see that yes they are
absolutely the the example is everything
in all areas of parenting
oh yes amen
totally we might be like upset our
children for doing something but if we
reflect inward we're like actually i do
that and that's probably why they were
yelling like that
exactly exactly yeah so it makes me
think of my husband and how his i
we started dating when we were 15 and 16
and his dad helped i think his dad
bought his first car but it was a
thousand dollar car and i remember being
like wow a thousand dollars but but hey
it got him from point a to point b and
it taught my husband a lesson about like
we're not just gonna spend
you know just spend money just because
like you know your first car can be a
thousand dollars and so i can't remember
if
my husband like helped him pay for it or
worked for the thousand dollars or if he
paid for it or not but that was that was
interesting to me because like my family
didn't really live as much like that
like being super careful but something
they did do that i think was really
helpful for me was they started a like a
regular checking account for us when we
were quite young i think we were like
maybe 14 or something and they told us
look any money that you put in there
that you earn on your own either from
working at home or when you get a job
because i think i got my first job at 15
or something um
whatever you put in there will double it
just to teach me to save it and not
spend it and that that was helpful for
me because then by the time that i
graduated high school i think i had like
six thousand dollars in there or
something and that was like a lot for me
at the time like six thousand but that
was money i had decided to put in there
but because there was that incentive of
like interest right if you will of
doubling it then it made me want to save
more rather than spend it on something
that i wasn't ever going to actually use
long term i'd love that yes and i would
say that too when they turn that 14-15
that's what my parents did they put
money in an account every month and said
you're in charge of this so you can't
ask us for money what's in this account
is there and if you want more you gotta
go get a job
and
in true like dave ramsey fashion i feel
like he like took the amount of money we
should have had and cut it in half
because he like basically made us get
jobs because it was basically no money
in the account yeah yeah but but
learning how to work a checking account
and then for our car
we had to save up and pay for half of it
so they did the same thing they matched
whatever we saved so
even out of that account i was like i
don't want to spend some of this because
i could use it towards my car
and get a better car because it's going
to double if i keep you know like yeah
you re you think through it all when
you're that age so putting those lessons
in i think is so important
yes oh it's such a good conversation
um so i was going to ask my last
question for you about your book and i
do want to talk about that but i i know
my husband will be mad at me if i don't
ask you this question about inflation he
said he was talking about how inflation
is a big thing right now so how do we
best protect our money from inflation
yes it's so hard it's i think it's at a
40-year high as of right now
and you know and i think a lot of things
have caused this i mean i mean
everything from supply and demand from
um you know the idea that the world was
shut down for a while and no one was
working and so
then when things but then substance and
just turn back on it takes time to work
everything out and get things out in the
market but now people are you know three
people are wanting one item when before
there are three items and now there's
one item because you know i mean i think
it's just a lot of that supply and
demand stuff and even the war with
russia and ukraine i mean everything
going on right with gas prices i mean
there's just so many factors in it and
so
right now it's at seven point nine
percent and so we're finding that for
the average americans anywhere from
three to six hundred dollars more
they're paying on things they were
paying even just this time last year so
so our food is more expensive our gas is
more expensive utilities if we're if
hotels you know i mean you look at
everything and everything is just more
so that's even more of a reason
to do what we're talking about this
whole podcast i mean it's even more of a
reason to budget and to know
specifically where your money's going
it's even that much more important to
get out of debt so you have more money
freed up right so like all of this stuff
it is so key but yeah the inflation it's
a it's a big deal and it's in it and it
has hurt a lot of people because
man everything's just it's just more and
so um hopefully it goes down in the next
12 months you know like obviously it's
everyone's prayer we don't have a
crystal ball we don't know but uh but
yeah it is it's a big factor right now
for a lot of people okay cool so lastly
can you kind of tell people where they
can learn more about you and about your
book know yourself know your money just
tell me a little bit about that so
people can just continue to get inspired
by you oh thank you so my latest book is
know yourself know your money and for
this book i
i didn't want to just talk about the
how-to of money you know done that a lot
on this podcast is you know just here's
what you do here's how you get out of
debt here's how you budget and all that
is so important to win
uh but with this book i wanted to kind
of go under that foundation and figure
out why do we handle money the way we do
you know why do we spend the money we
spend
why do we save the way we save why do we
give the way we give like all of this
the answer of why and it's everything
from how you grew up to your tendencies
around money to your personality to your
dreams to your your money fears there's
a lot of motivation to why you handle
money the way you do so i really wanted
to break all of that down because
there's a part of me too that i'm like
you know we're the ones that are
handling it
why don't we have a little bit of
self-awareness on why we do what we do
so that we can change our money habits
so that's the newest book called know
yourself know your money and um yeah
it's it's been it hit the new york times
like two months after it launched which
is just so funny i was you know you're
kind of looking as an author but okay
did it do well and and then it and then
it and then it kind of spiked again
which was awesome so i think it's helped
hopefully my prayer is that it's helped
a lot of people that's why i write books
i'm like i want this information out uh
to help people change their money habits
so that's the book but yeah they can
find um you guys can find me anywhere i
have a podcast the rachel cruz show
wherever you listen to podcasts and a
youtube version as well
and rachelcruz.com c-r-u-z-e and i'm on
all social media so instagram twitter
facebook all of it
amazing awesome well i really appreciate
this conversation i can't wait to read
your book it's in the mail right now and
i haven't read it yet but i have a
feeling it's going to be really good and
i cannot wait to get my hands on it so
this has been such a good conversation
and i appreciate all the aspects of the
ways that you share you know down to
down to the exact nitty-gritty of like
this is what you do but also the mindset
behind so much of it because that is
such a powerful component to it so yeah
again thank you i think this was
fabulous and absolutely thank you ellen
thanks for having me on of course all
right bye everyone
[Music]
you